what makes something satisfying
what if we each just took a few days to
make the most satisfying render we could
possibly think of one of these fine
gentlemen is gonna get this computer if
they win this challenge
thanks to simply say for sponsoring this
video stick around to find out how you
can get this award-winning home security
system
tactical three loads is done we just
spent the last few weeks working on
visual effects for it so we're a little
burnt out from doing effects so i think
it's time to kind of redirect our energy
towards something a little bit more
satisfying i was i was watching some
like really satisfying simulations on
instagram and i realized you know what
now's the perfect time for us to try
that so we're going to be kind of like
figuring out today what exactly we want
to simulate and how we make it
satisfying first off
what makes something satisfying what's
the best of the last month
what the heck oh my god that's just
terrifying is something
satisfying if it's all so creepy well
that's personal you know
ooh nice i like that it's pretty sweet
oh and it loops it looks see that's
another thing i think a good
gif needs to perfectly loop yeah agreed
i agree 100 so rule number one it has to
loop
yes
yes
see that's satisfying that's
satisfying i think that actually is
another thing that goes into the
satisfaction is like it looks extremely
real it looks like you can touch it and
like the more you can like taste it and
touch it the better dude it's like
visual asmr it is 100
[Music]
here here we're starting to get yeah
this is starting to get there
[Music]
whoa
this is this is peak yeah this is top
notch right here
oh that's satisfying
the motion is satisfying here because it
always just barely lines up perfectly it
has everything it's that perfect fit
it's looping the colors and the design
is really well done it feels like i can
touch it it's rendered very well it's
lit very well this is what i'm trying to
emulate here with my render there's so
many different things we could simulate
here like what are you guys i
am going to do something food related oh
you are nice okay okay i'm probably
going to do a smoke simulation ooh
because i've started messing around with
this program called ambergen i
definitely want to do a japanese themed
wooden something hearing the sound of
like hollow bamboo going
against each other and like
i feel like half of this is gonna be in
the sound design oh here's a challenge
we all have to do sound design but we're
not allowed to use any sound effects
only our mouth i'm gonna accept your
challenge it's a great idea and it's a
way for me to make my render feel more
tangible for smoke i'm just gonna like
blow into the mic like
uh puget like rushed a call yesterday
with me and jake and said hey nvidia
really wants to work with us they're
like do you guys know these guys named
quarter digital they wanted puget to
make a fully custom system integrated
with their new rtx 3090. it's going to
be a cg vfx wizard computer oh i don't
want the 39 computers are going to go to
wren or peter so it could be the prize
for this competition here this is not
supposed to be the stakes for this video
peter is
ready to be uncaged and unleashed on
this tournament right now
yeah if i win i get to decide who gets
it because i'm already set up with a
nice system i have the power to choose
between ren or peter so normally when we
do these runner challenges we only have
a small amount of time no
no
not today we're going to put all of our
effort to make sure that we can do the
best that we can do
so we will take the rest of this week to
work on our renders and at the end of it
sam anika will judge them to see which
ones are the most satisfactory 2020 has
been a year of non-satisfying events and
we are here to end that
damn
damn damn
statues of the gods
this must be their garden all right so
i've been playing a ton of ghosts of
tsushima and i'm totally obsessed i mean
i just i love the japanese culture been
there twice the looping animation to me
is very peaceful it's very zen so i went
with a little zen garden experience a
looping infinite circle this represents
a whole lot of things but in my case it
just represents life and death creation
and destruction there's a whole lot of
stuff going on with that but basically
when i'm putting together this japanese
zen garden i am trying to gather as many
like references as possible so that i
can model all this stuff by hand in c4d
from scratch
so i have an idea for my render
basically i want to make this box about
yay big and on it it says perfect
breakfast
and it unfolds into a tiny factory that
sole purpose is to make the perfect
breakfast the reason i want to do this
is because back when i lived in san
francisco me and the old ball and chain
would be eating breakfast and we would
we would always make this toast with
cream cheese and oregano and tomato so i
want to make a render that's satisfying
auditorially in the tactile sense and
emotionally because isn't that what it's
all about hey buddy come here
who's a good boy gizmo
all right i'm here and the idea that
i've come up with to do is to basically
3d scan my head and have like my
nostrils or my eyeballs or my mouth or
something emit smoke and it's going to
be cold smoke so it actually falls
rather than rises that's not all i'm
going to do i'm going to try to actually
stick my head in the ground a little bit
so that i have a bit of a static scene
for the smoke to interact with the way
i'm making this food in the render is
i'm actually using a process called
photogrammetry which is taking a camera
and orbiting around an object while
taking photos and then you feed these
photos to a software in the computer
which calculates the position of the
camera and then finds common points in
the photos and reconstructs the geometry
based on those points so that's what i
did for the toast i did one scan of just
the toast and then one scan of the toast
with cream cheese on it and then one
scan of the toast with cream cheese and
oregano and tomato on it and then i'm
going to hopefully seamlessly blend
these different 3d models together in
the final render so i i've now clumped
my head into the grass here my whole
head and the background are just a photo
frame it's still and not moving but my
eyes
are moving there's kind of some weird
uncomfortable artifacting going on i'm
already afraid that this isn't going to
be a satisfying simulation because i
think this is just going to kind of be a
little bit of some nightmare fuel
this is the uv map for my face
this is the texture that wraps around
the 3d model of my head
like i said nightmare fuel
so my goal here is to figure out how i
can animate the rake here around the zen
garden
seamlessly what i did first was made
sure that these rocks were duplicated
180 degrees onto this other side that's
so i can get the perfect symmetry
because camera is only going around the
circle by half so 180 degrees i'm not
doing a 360. once i got this right i'm
going into photoshop and i'm using this
render as a reference so what i'm going
to do is use a brush i'm going to
basically draw the perfect pattern and
then i'll duplicate it onto the other
side so everything on the left is an
exact duplicate of what is on the right
okay so it's a perfect 180 it loops
seamlessly so once i have this
displacement map then i can finally
bring it back into cinema 4d and
displace my sand anything that's gray
stays where it is and anything that is
darker can go down or up depending on
where i choose now the last challenge i
have for myself with this rake is to
figure out how to get the actual rake to
look like it's raking across the sand i
don't want to simulate it that's going
to be way too intense so what i had to
do is actually animate the displacement
map in after effects with just some
animated masks here then i had to line
that up drop it in as a displacement map
in cinema 4d
and it actually worked it gave a pretty
nice result i thought so okay
i now know how to use ember gen but
first i gotta take this shot into cinema
4d so that i can actually build out the
scene add some geometry like my head and
the fence and then i'll bring that into
ambrogen where i will simulate some
smoke and exactly what i will be
simulating i have yet to figure out so
coffee is important for making renders
it's not i'm it's just a chemical
dependency so the biggest challenge i'm
having right now is how to actually
construct this thing i feel like i need
to be an engineer to do this because to
make something that fits inside a box
can unfold and then be a functioning
factory that could realistically make
its own breakfast is much more
challenging than i thought it would be
so kudos to the people who make these
kinds of renders every other day
it is 2 30 a.m i'm trying to get myself
very weak
managed to import some simple geometry
for the fence and that 3d mesh my head
basically everywhere that's red the
smoke is not going to simulate and it is
going to simulate in there and what i
did was i put little smoke emitters like
on my nostrils and my ears and i spent
the last several hours just kind of like
dialing in the settings to get something
that looked interesting look at that
that's basically real time isn't that
crazy it might be pretty cool
i i'm starting to have doubts this is
going to be satisfying
[Music]
so today i'm going into the studio to
show everybody the render i was up until
3 a.m last night banging away on this
thing i was way too ambitious it took
way too much time man to be honest i i
kind of bit off a bit more than i can
chew with this thing now again i had a
couple problems here in the end still
i'd have to spend a few more hours with
it but i just don't have the time we got
to get this in and deliver it within the
next like couple hours here although
this video was super challenging to make
it was really fun you have this idea in
your head starting out and you have no
idea how it's going to take shape or if
it's even going to work and then you
just start throwing stuff together and
stuff starts working and you're like
this is really satisfying so this render
wasn't just satisfying to watch but
man it was satisfying to make good luck
to peter good luck to wren because i
think i did a pretty good job here let's
see what sam and nico think
this was way more of a challenge than i
thought it would be for clint clint made
it a much bigger challenge for himself
because he decided to be super ambitious
about it which i can relate to i've been
there why are you trying to like render
out a volume at like 3 000 samples
time to take a look at the render from
peter
[Music]
[Music]
it's sort of loose it's like
it's a cop-out loop it's a whip pan you
could you could have made this loop with
just a little bit more effort
all right
this is a nine out of ten oh
this is definitely a 9 out of 10. it's
way beyond what i was expecting to see
in this render challenge also the amount
of detail is nuts
uh i deduct one because honestly the
loop is a cap out oh yeah that's what
i'm saying nine to ten because it
doesn't loop so great
i am honestly incredibly impressed peter
you have come a long way with your
blender abilities over the last few
years remember when we did that
competition a few years ago run doesn't
stand a [ __ ] chance
i'm gonna destroy that piece of [ __ ] all
right let's check out this render
oh whoa
that's so sick i'd say this is very
satisfying unfortunately there are still
several things i'd like to fix about it
there's like i did like the whole like
grass mat technique with my neck you
know but i didn't deal with my shadows
so my i have like this harsh shadow from
my head going along the ground okay i
noticed the hard line across the grass
you'd need a little bit of displacement
in there to just you know offset that
shadow a little bit or even photoshop
just
well i gave this uh
eight out of ten
booze
because
a happy halloween rent look as far as a
satisfying render goes i give it a 5 out
of 10.
i'm sorry i don't mean to go real harsh
new as far as like a technical render
goes it's like a 7 out of 10. obviously
the theme is not satisfying whatsoever
the smoke puffs out satisfyingly it's
very very clean it's like for as far as
renders go like it's very high res it's
very clean but i also will point out it
is a flawless loop i did notice that
your smoke continues and snooping smoke
is tricky i wonder what clint scott
because currently peter's in a heavy
lead
heavy lead
heavily pretty heavy lead i want to
point out that i held to the initial
rules i have a flawless loop i have
sound design from my mouth clint what
do you really i was like blowing into
the mic i was like
nice how much sound did you produce from
your mouth clint you broke i forgot i
forgot i forgot i'm gonna accept your
challenge well it wasn't a requirement
it was like a it was a bonus environment
we all agreed to do all of the sound
design using just our mouths it was a
rule for the challenge clint totally
broke the rules he should be
disqualified i didn't check a box all
right i didn't break a rule oh guys
wait a second huge hit heard her making
satisfying renders and they needed some
satisfaction so they gave us a new
computer with a 30 90 in it this
literally just came in right now that is
the computer we talked about here too
one of these fine gentlemen is gonna get
this computer if they win this challenge
god dang it i bit off way more than i
get you on this one
uh stop this is how each one starts
everyone's like oh this one sucks
render it at 720 by 404.
deleted
[Music]
no it doesn't loop on your posh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
did it just loop yeah
okay
that's a good loop how does this brush
does it go through this rock here yeah
i made everything everything's from by
hand except for obviously the mega scans
i do have one question though yes
if i'm not mistaken one of the current
requirements was make the sounds with
your mouth so if you could demonstrate
the babbling brook for us the batman
book first yeah all right ready
so that's the brook all right and the uh
the the big bell sounded so rich
[Music]
okay thank you uh that's all i needed
thank you clint this is really good yeah
that's super cool man i think sam and i
are going to need to deliberate
privately okay here let's deliberate
right here just out of your shot
all right so clint was really good and
arguably
had all the elements of a satisfying
render but it was really noisy to the
point where it's flickery clint had a
really good one but it looks like he was
like about a day behind on getting it
done render was rushed it's super grainy
kind of looks like a cinematic from like
a 90s game satisfying though but
not as satisfying as peters
[Music]
three of you delivered some excellent
renders today some of them were
complicated
some of the more technical achievements
some of them had immense satisfaction
with incredible loops but only one could
be a winner
i must inform you
[Music]
you guys are all great
you're still all great we still love you
all can i have your old computer peter
that's my seat now son
congratulations thank you i have the
fattest head huge man listen i'm very
used to losing so this is fine
[Laughter]
what i initially wanted to do was far
more ambitious than i knew i was capable
of and so i listened to myself to not do
the more ambitious thing
how many times have you learned this
lesson i don't learn it that's the thing
i don't learn this lesson dude i want to
make these awesome things that i see in
my head i i could have smoothed out some
edges if i had scaled back a little bit
but dude honestly same i bit off so much
more than i could chew it's always just
analyzing how much you want to
die per project because i could have
worked on this for a month but being
like brought back down to a week made me
crunch so hard and i thought i was gonna
be able to do so much more than i was
and i always am learning this lesson of
finding off more than i can chew and
regretting it but then having something
i'm happy with so it's just that balance
it can always be better
but you gotta find the point at where
it's like good enough and still
awesome while still not taking all your
time so you can move on
come here baby
[Applause]